the dense tropical rainforests of
Liberia are a haven for the closest of
human relatives the chimpanzee but as
the nation recovers from years of civil
war
the chimps habitat is emptying fast
experts say most chimps in the wild will
be extinct in the next few decades due
to a thriving trade in bush meat I
recently visited Liberia to join
primatologist hail Markel from the Max
Planck Institute for evolutionary
anthropology he and his colleagues set
up the pan Africa great a program in
Liberia which is the first of 15 nations
to host a systematic survey of their
chimpanzee populations with such a grave
full cast for the chimpanzee this
project aims to gain as much information
about them as possible
before they disappear the Liberian
landscape can be treacherous local teams
often have to struggle through uncut
bush across raging rivers and over roads
which become mud traps in the rainy
season in South Pole National Park
Liberia's only protected reserve
volunteer Vera Lynette has set up video
cameras to observe the chimps in their
natural environment these cameras are
triggered by infrared motion sensors as
chimps pass by though Vera's been in
South Pole for a year now she's yet to
see a single chimp face-to-face on the
plus side capturing footage of these
playful creatures has enabled her to
really get to know the chimp community
this kind of data is proving invaluable
for studying chimps health in the wild
and a shedding light on concepts such as
animal culture reporting for nature
video and guides rewriting arson
you